[Music]
now I haven't seen you since Becca
Tilly's blog party and I got to ask you
a tough question you were there with
Josh that night what is your
relationship status right now so Josh
and I have decided to break up something
actually haven't talked about it yet
just because it's been a little hard and
I haven't really thought about what to
say but yeah we did break up I've had it
is sad can I can I ask just because you
guys seemed happy that night it was only
a few weeks ago and everybody loves you
and wants you to be so happy so what do
you think went wrong
I just think um there's some things in a
relationship that you can work on or
nobody's perfect but then there's also
things that you just can't work on and
things that you just know aren't going
to work out in the long run so yeah just
normal relationship things at the end of
the day I think you know it's hard he
moved you know across the country to
live with us and I think you know at the
end of day we're just very different
people and things just didn't work out
well he was super close with your girls
how did you explain that to them or will
he be in touch with them at all anymore
it was actually it was pretty good
timing so we ended things right before
the holidays and the next day my mom
flew out my dad my sister her boyfriend
we had the entire family there so I
think it was a good transition I'm kind
of having my entire family there so it
was a little easier for them
you